da gibt es diesen satz wenn der rat über
industrie sprechen
richtung automobilindustrie annalena
baerbock jedes verbot ist auch ein
innovationstreiber erstmal an jasmin m
barek die frage was geht ihnen durch den
kopf wenn sie so ein satz hören ich
glaube dass diese also dieser satz wenn
wir schon bei polarisierung sind und
wahlkampf den hat sie relativ und
überlegt gesagt das hat man im moment
auch gemerkt er sagt ist in seiner gänze
natürlich völlig falsch und so gewährt
das völlig falsche also dass sie das
gesagt hat zeigt so ein bisschen dass
sie auch relativ schnell voreilig wird
und dann sachen so raushaut die halt
wenn man sie sich jetzt vorstellt hat
zumal neben irgendwelche anderen
regierungschefs playoffs gesagt wie
wichtig ist der sack ist eigentlich so
komplett falsch oder es ist sozusagen
nur eine andere perspektive auf die
frage wie kommen bist du zu innovationen
dass er die entscheiden natürlich auf
einer metaebene gemeint gewesen aber man
muss sehr aufpassen wie man seine
sprache verwendet in dem fall war es
einfach falsch sie hat es vier klarer
definieren können hätte dieser satz auch
keiner explosionskraft gehabt ich würde
sagen dass der satz einfach sehr ehrlich
ist weil ich meine wir haben doch zum
beispiel der automobilindustrie gesehen
dass wir in den letzten jahren schon
viele entwicklungen verschlafen haben
das ist auch ein thema was man in bezug
auf china oder auch usa industriepolitik
auch noch ansprechen könnte das
natürlich am ende auch die
verbrennungsmotoren auf den märkten der
zukunft die klimaneutral sein werden
nicht die große perspektive haben und da
ist doch zum beispiel eine regelung dass
wir sagen ab 20.30 wollen wir zumindest
keine neuen verbrennungsmotoren mehr
zulassen und bringen diese diskussion
ins gespräch auch mit der deutschen
automobilindustrie ist natürlich ein
innovationstreiber weil es natürlich
klare regeln setzt und auch druck macht
dafür
in neue antriebstechnologien zu
investieren und darüber auch
nachzudenken da das kapital hin zu
schieben und genau so war dieser satz ja
auch gemeint und deswegen ist er in
dieser form natürlich auch genau richtig
und auch ehrlich gesagt das was wir
brauchen und wir haben ja auch bei der
automobil-industrie gesehen dass viele
in den chefetagen jetzt selber sagen ja
klar das machen wir vor zwanzig dreißig
und ich glaube schon dass diese debatte
natürlich auch ein umdenken gerade bei
innovation und gerade bei diesem
wichtigen bereich den wenn der deutschen
industrie haben das ist ja ein ganz
kleiner hat punkt und ist ein echter
paradigmenwechsel im zweifel das ist ja
eine zwei denkschulen herr merz also die
frage ist ob du sozusagen über verbote
zur innovation kommst oder ob du sagst
was auf wir geben euch einen rahmen vor
und dann macht ihr das mein thema mit
den verbot oder meine frage in dem
zusammenhang was passiert wenn wir alles
verbieten und dann hoffen dann wird
schon innovationen geben wer verbietet
wann was wer legt das fest was zu
verbieten ist also wer entscheidet
daumen hoch daumen runter das ist offene
fragen gar nicht der punkt dass der
alles verbieten wollen das ist damit ja
auch nicht gemeint sondern wir haben ja
einen dreiklang also wir wollen
investieren in zukunftstechnologien und
dafür auch die industrie fördern und die
mittel bereitstellen die solche
investitionen und innovationen daneben
auch kosten und zum anderen wollen wir
natürlich auch anreize setzen zb mit der
co2 bepreisung das heißt wir wollen das
wird oft so suggeriert wir wollen
irgendwie alles über verbote regeln
bestimmt nicht er sondern wir wollen
erst mit einem dreiklang aus anreizen
durch co2 preisen investitionen und eben
auch klaren rahmenbedingungen und wir
sehen doch dass diese diskussion auch
gefruchtet hat und man auch sieht dass
die industrie mittlerweile weiter ist
als die deutsche bundesregierung die
über diese 20.30 frage gar nicht
diskutieren wie sehen sie das so ja dass
die deutsche autoindustrie weiter
zum beispiel gesehen oder steht die
deutsche autoindustrie möglicherweise an
einem punkt an dem es irgendwann
existenziell wird bei der frage über die
verbrennungsmotoren haben wir schon
gesehen dass die manager von größeren
automobilherstellern gesagt haben es ist
für uns auch unwirtschaftlich
ab 20.30 noch neu verbrenner zuzulassen
deswegen werden wir wahrscheinlich sogar
vorher schon aussteigen und komplett auf
andere antriebe umgestellt haben worauf
ich hinaus will herr merz ist das licht
dieses sehr klein kleine deutsche denken
na ja das kann man sich mit herbert
diess hier mich engagiert es ging um die
frage hatte sozusagen die deutsche
autoindustrie ihre nokia moment schon ja
sie sind hier lesen berühmten moment
nokia feiert das beste ergebnis seiner
firmengeschichte in helsinki und 2008
glaube ich und ein jahr zuvor stellt ein
gewisser steve jobs in cupertino in
kalifornien seine serie namens iphone
vorn die feiern etwas
was zu feiern das oder ist sogar nicht
dass das ende bereits an dem punkt
gewonnen hat und die fragen für die
deutsche autoindustrie ist doch und da
macht sich jemand wie herr aber dies zum
beispiel sorgen in dem moment wo ein
auto ein smartphone auf rädern ist ein
die weiß wie man neudeutsch sagt ja ein
mobiles endgerät
spätestens dann entscheidet sich doch
die frage wo die reise hingeht und da
sind wir doch so weit zurück also tesla
ist ja kein zufall dass elon musk dieses
auto als software begreifen als
prozessor begreift gleichzeitig
satelliten ins all schießt google macht
das gleiche apple amazon die
investierende genau diese dinge weil es
um daten geht wer es um selbst fahren um
uns selbst fahren der autor geht um
autonomes fahren geht dann brauchst du
daten aus dem all um dieses auto zu
steuern und zu lenken ich sehe keinen
deutschen autokonzern der satelliten ins
all ich sehe vor allem kann man
deutschen autokonzern der aufgrund von
verboten innovativ wird also elon musk
und tesla ist doch nicht das geworden
was sie heute sind wir in amerika
irgendetwas verboten worden ist sondern
im gegenteil sie haben rahmenbedingungen
geschaffen sie haben ein ökosystem in
silicon valley was solche firmen möglich
macht und das haben wir nicht und wir
sind ja auch nicht bereit darüber zu
reden dass daten eine wahre sein können
über die man mal auch innovation und
auch wertschöpfung ermöglicht so und so
lange wir das so betreiben dass uns mal
zugespitzt zu sagen also wie groß ist
die gefahr dass so große konzerne
grossarth der konzern auch wie daimler
volkswagen und andere dass du irgendwann
einfach black lieferanten sind dieser
liefert die karosserie sehr groß und die
anderen liefern dir dass du bist fast
die komplette abhängigkeit von diesen
großen ton die gefahr wird noch größer
werden das passiert was die grünen gerne
hätten dass nämlich ab 20.30 der
verbrenner verboten wird in dem
augenblick wo der verbrenner verboten
wird hört die forschung und die
entwicklung an neuen motoren und
besseren co2 werten auf
und nur mal wir müssen wir immer zahlen
sagen ist zurzeit 50 millionen rentner
in deutschland über die straße und 220
millionen in europa dezember an die zahl
geht jetzt langsam runter wegen
elektromobilität nicht sehr schnell aber
sie geht runter dann haben wir 20 30
immer noch 30 millionen in deutschland
um noch 150 millionen verbrenne auf der
straße in europa was man heute neuerlich
wie schaffen wir eigentlich dieser autos
co2 hinzubekommen die forschung und
entwicklung an diesen motoren wir haben
die beste automobilindustrie der welt
wir haben die besten verbrennungsmotoren
wir haben die besten diesel wir haben
die besten 60 das geschäft der zukunft
ist alles wahr ist was ist denn heute
das ist denn morgen ein auto genau das
wird das genauso sein wie wie wie der
tesla ist das ein
datenverarbeitungssystem mit rädern
möglicherweise ja nur das ist zurzeit
eine nische und der verbrenner wird nach
meiner einschätzung müssen nicht teilen
aber der wird bei lkws bei schiffen bei
flugzeugen bei vielen anderen maschinen
weiter notwendig bleiben wir müssen
verbrenner co2 neutral herstellen wenn
wir sie verbieten ist die arbeit in
deutschland daran beendet und zwar auf
dem höchsten technischen niveau das auf
der welt gibt wie wir stellen sie dann
einfach ein und überlassen das andere
wir haben in diesem land zu viel
verboten wir steigen in diesem land zu
viel aus wenn sie die regeln zu wenig
leichter bei 16 jahre cdu habe merz das
ist nicht 16 jahre cdu sei es ist auch
aber ich gucken sich mal die diskussion
über die kernenergie ich will jetzt
nicht so eine billige seien billiger
machen sie auch das ist natürlich 16
jahre cdu weist ein solches ich glaube
große teile meiner partei bereuen heute
dass sie sich von dieser anti atomkraft
bewegung dazu haben bringen lassen zu
einem falschen zeitpunkt aus der
kanadier doch jetzt gerade wieder machen
als wir schauen was funktioniert nicht
was haben wir falsch gemacht und die
haben doch jetzt die situation dass wir
in diesem jahr einen anstieg an co2
emissionen hatten den wir seit 1990
nicht mehr hatten und dass wir gerade
krank um die klimaziele verfehlen ja das
liegt daran dass in der vergangenheit zu
wenig getan wurde da gebe ich ihnen ja
recht aber lassen wir uns doch jetzt
darüber sprechen was wir tun wir uns
endlich um klimaneutralität zu erreichen
und ist doch völlig unbestritten und ich
finde es auch erstmal gut dass sich da
alle demokratischen parteien einig sind
dass wir die pariser klimazielen
ausziehen müssen
natürlich auch konkret darüber sprechen
welche maßnahmen er wirklich braucht und
kann nicht immer nur sagen das
funktioniert nicht das funktioniert
nicht das für dich will nur über dinge
die vom probieren ja ja nein das haben
sie gerade nicht gemacht und ich meine
wenn man auch einen blick in das
wahlprogramm der union wirft dann ist es
ja so dass sie zum einen auch sagen wir
wollen
innovationen irgendwie herstellen aber
wir finden eigentlich ordnungsrecht
generell eher gängeleien für die
industrie und auf der anderen seite
verwehren wir uns auch gegenüber
investitionen weil wir eigentlich sagen
wir bleiben bei der schuldenbremse und
der schwarze null so wie sie es stehen
und genau damit verpassen wir den weg in
die zukunft weil wir jetzt für unsere
industrie für den weg in die
klimaneutralität auch um das sozial
gerecht zu schaffen und um unseren
wirtschaftsstandort zu erhalten geld
mobilisieren müssen also da gibt es eine
studie vom
dgb und vom bdi also vom bund der
deutschen industrie er die die gesagt
hat noch vor der korona krise wir
brauchen ein 450 milliarden in den
nächsten zehn jahren für den weg in die
klimaneutralität davon habe ich in ihrem
wahlprogramm überhaupt nichts gelesen
und natürlich müssen wir auch die
erneuerbaren energien endlich ausbauen
damit wir diesen weg in eine
klimaneutrale wirtschaft endlich
schaffen habe ich auch nicht viel in
ihrem wahlprogramm gelesen jetzt reden
über sex und warum irgendwie nicht den
einfachen weg um und bauen die
erneuerbaren energien endlich aus da
erwarte ich mir konkrete antworten
gerade wenn sie sagen sie wollen
klimaneutralität erreichen und
gleichzeitig die industrie nach vorne
bringen da führt kein weg dran vorbei
die erneuerbaren energien endlich
auszubauen wir haben ein bisschen über
die automobilindustrie gesprochen genau
und jetzt sprechen wir über eine ganz
andere ganz anderes thema aber
zusammen gegen das versprechen ja nur
wir haben sie in dieser sendung ja auch
schon mal in anderer zusammensetzung ja
auch und wir werden mit erneuerbaren
allein den energiebedarf dieser
volkswirtschaft nicht decken daher sieht
seitliches trier also das sagt als eine
wissenschafterin wie wir ja auch schon
mal sitzen gehabt haben eine wissen dass
wir so schnell geht wie in einem von den
grünen geführten bundesland baden
württemberg
dann dauert es noch ein paar sie wissen
ja selber dass das zum beispiel den
südländern zu wenig an den
ausschreibungen beteiligung da gewesen
ist weil einfach von der bundesebene
viel zu wenig möglichkeiten
da brauchen sie jetzt auch nicht
suggerieren dass das anders wäre wir
haben erlebt dass die große koalition
mit beteiligung ihrer partei den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien massiv
zurückgenommen hat was uns wie gesagt
als industriestandort auch nach hinten
geworfen hat und auch dazu beigetragen
hat dass andere viel zu wenig ausgebaut
haben und ganz konkrete in ihrem
bundesland verhindert jetzt armin
laschet durch eine rücknahme der flächen
die für windkraft überhaupt zur
verfügung gestellt werden können dass es
da weiter ausgebaut werden kann und da
brauchen wir endlich ein umdenken und da
ist ihre patente interesse auf der
bremse und mal ganz kurz weil sie das
gerade ansprechen die schwarz gelbe
landesregierungen in der kabine will bis
zum jahr 2030 insgesamt
bezahlen jetzt aber trotzdem machten das
hat sich das auf der zunge zergehen zu
lassen
10.500 megawatt windkraft installieren
endet 20 20 waren aber nur 6200 in
betrieb und reiner priggen dass der
vorsitzende des landesverbandes
erneuerbare energien sachs sagt selbst
wenn wir am jahresende bei etwas mehr
als 300 megawatt zubau landen lassen
sich damit die ziele bis 2030 nicht im
entferntesten erreichen ja und dann muss
ich frage mich frage mich ganz
grundsätzlich auch mit mit blick auf sie
frau schäfer und auch im blick auf sie
haben wir da möglicherweise ein
grundsätzliches problem
also wird das funktionieren der
energiebedarf steigt in einem in einem
wahnsinnigen aus dass wir im nächsten
jahrzehnt häuser der sanierung und so
weiter sind ja alles themen die noch
kommt
machen wir uns da was vor frauenberg sie
haben sich damit auch schon beschäftigt
also ich finde dass das eher diskurs
einen ursprung das ist nämlich fukushima
weil wir da angefangen haben zwei
polarisieren seiten diesen druck
freizugeben die union hat sich dem
gebeugt dass der druck da war zu sagen
okay wir steigen aus der atomenergie aus
was ich interessant finde ist auch dass
es jetzt langsam der union anfängt so
genau um diese entscheidung stationen
doch weil auch eben legal kretschmann
gestern auf dem podium darüber
gesprochen hat dass man das ja
eigentlich mal wieder hochholen könnte
und das ist genau das was meine meinte
kernenergie genau also auch das nicht
länger laufen lässt weil das problem ist
eigentlich dass man so lange sagt wir
setzen auf innovation und es kommt und
es konsole nicht gekommen und man jetzt
erst darauf angewiesen ist dass auch in
der eu leute uns das importieren können
und zweitens das ist ja viel zu spät ist
um jetzt so auszubauen dass wir sagen es
hat er das tun 20 wird es alles so in
betrieb sein dass wir nur erneuerbare
haben weil auch und der rückblick auf
eine grüne landesregierung beteiligung
wird es ja auch nicht passieren direkt
das 325 davon ausgehen kann dass ich
einmal ganz kurz kam am sonntag in dem
tri l gab es an wie ich fand sehr
bemerkenswerten moment hat armin laschet
genau darüber gesprochen und er setzte
an eigentlich irgendwie lag der gedanke
in der luft befinden interessieren wie
sie das wahrgenommen haben wir mal ganz
kurz rein
fakt ist seit 1900 den neunziger jahren
wissen wir von weltklima ereignissen wir
wissen seit monaten von frey des verf
user die auf der straße sind dass etwas
passieren muss wir sehen
unwetterkatastrophen überall in der welt
wir sehen brennende und merken wie das
klima sich verändert und deshalb ist
nicht erst in dem moment wo wir selbst
auch mal erwischt sind der zeitpunkt für
eine politik änderung da die die findet
statt sie findet übrigens in der
falschen priorität statt wenn das thema
so wichtig ist wie ich es halte er war
die reihenfolge in deutschland falsch
zuerst aus der kernenergie auszusteigen
und dann aus der kohle das ist jetzt
geschichte aber der weg war falsch
brauchen noch etwas sagt dann damit und
dann herr merz erst die politische
könnte dieser sei dann sei es unabhängig
voneinander passiert aber die grünen
haben auch ein teil die das bestimmt
jetzt anders sehen würden als dass man
sie trotz 2020 wenn man sieht ja was 16
jahre unions regierung gemacht haben mit
den erneuerbaren energien dass laschet
das jetzt so hm halbsatz verschwurbelt
sagt zeigt eigentlich ist das thema
nicht gegessen ist aber er sieht schulz
machen möchte derjenige zu sein der
dieses fast wieder aufmacht und sie
machen das jetzt vielleicht
aber es ist ja märz wieder auf nein ich
sage mal so wir sagen beide dasselbe die
reihenfolge war falsch und ich komme ja
nun auch aus nordrhein-westfalen haben
bis 2017 eine rot grün geführte
landesregierung hat deren umweltminister
johannes remmel die letzten braunkohle
kraftwerke genehmigt hat den letzten
braunkohletagebau genehmigt hat und die
abholzung des hambacher festes genehmigt
hat bis 2017 ist nicht 1917 sondern 2017
so das heißt das nicht gerade mal vier
jahre zurück so jetzt steuern wir das
ganze um und versuchen das beste daraus
zu machen aber das ist natürlich ein
hochkomplexer technologischer prozess im
übrigen die windenergie in deutschland
ja wenn die verfahren 67 jahre brauchen
bis so eine anlage steht ich habe mir
vorher in der vorletzten woche mal in
husum einen großen windpark angesehen
das läuft hervorragend warum läuft so
gut weil da eine fläche da ist wo
viereinhalb stunden betriebs 400.000
stunden im jahr betriebsdauer für diese
windräder möglich sind an der
nordseeküste walter 12 bis 14.000
kommanditisten alle an diesen parks
beteiligt sind da läuft das weitgehend
konfliktfrei das ist aber mittlerweile
eine anlage in einer größenordnung die
vielen kernkraftwerken entspricht das
ist vernünftig ob ich bei mir im
sauerland auf jedem bergrücken sonne
windkraftanlage haben will weiß ich
nicht habe und ich will sie eigentlich
nicht als auch ökonomisch keinen sinn
macht ein zwei anlage hinzustellen die
lösen das problem nämlich nicht wir
brauchen große parade noch mal da
draußen wir auch die leitungen wir haben
die lehren aus dem norden in den süden
brauchen wir auch wenn sich bis 2030 ihr
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier hat
er neulich festgestellt dass wir dann
doch deutlich mehr strom brauchen als
seine leute berechnet hat die späte
erkenntnis aber sicher richtig wie kann
denn so was sagen eigentlich naja gut
die berechnungen waren ja alle falsch
und sie erinnern sich auch an eine
sendung hier habe ich schon mal gesagt
habe das könnte deutlich mehr werden das
doppelte mindestens so und die wussten
also nein ich habe es einfach noch
einmal ganz einfach mit dem
taschenrechner versucht auszurechnen wo
unser energiebedarf entstehen wie kann
denn das sein herr merz wie kann es denn
sein dass sie zu hause auf dem sofa auf
dem sie auf der strecke guckt haben
abends mit dem taschenrechner sitzen
oder vielleicht sogar auf einen
bierdeckel noch mal nein sagen irgendwie
was mal gucken wie viel strom brauchen
wir eigentlich und kommen dann zu einem
besseren ergebnis mit den
staatssekretären zur ehrenrettung des
bundeswirtschaftsministers sagen es hat
ja nun auch neu über rechnungen aus der
industrie gegeben schauen sie sich mal
an was die chemische industrie
mittlerweile sagen sie braucht für die
transformation in die co2 neutralität so
viel strom wie die gesamte deutsche
industrie heißt so das heißt also da
haben sich ja auch einzeln wochen
monaten vielleicht ein zwei jahren die
annahmen auch etwas geändert und darauf
muss doch auch eine volkswirtschaft mit
der ersten frage aber die entscheidende
frage heißt das sie halten es nicht für
ausgeschlossen dass wir die laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke verlängern darüber
spekuliere ich heute nicht ich bin mir
nur mein persönlich in der einschätzung
sicher dass wir mit dem weg in der
energieerzeugung in der stromerzeugung
den wir zurzeit gehen nicht auskommen um
ausreichend elektrizität um ausreichend
strom in deutschland zu haben um diese
drei müssen nicht regulieren aber was
taugen sie
werden sehr viel ein was alles nicht
funktioniert sagt
guter punkt also wir werden natürlich
sehr viel stärker noch auf importe
angewiesen sein wir importieren ja
ohnehin 70 prozent unserer primär
energie also deutschland ist ja nicht
nie im smi unabhängig von importen
gewesen 70 prozent unserer
primärenergiebedarf werde aber noch mal
wie lösen wir dieses riesige
energieprobleme der zukunft um in die
zukunft zu blicken ist doch die frage
sicherlich
halbjahr haben wir wieder unglaublich
viel kohle kraftwerke an geworfen weil
es ein sehr winters sohin war das ist
mehr als die hälfte unserer gesamten
energie kam wieder aus genau diesen cola
verwerte ja das wird es also doch das
ist das einfache möglichkeiten so lange
wir keine gute wasserstoff noch mal die
haare bleiben atomkraftwerke länger
laufen lassen oder nicht das ist eine
diskussion die wir wahrscheinlich im
nächsten jahr bekommen da will ich nicht
vorgreifen das weiß ich nicht das ist
doch albern wieso ist das alba nicht
passieren lassen doch offensichtlich der
satz von armin laschet weil ich ja das
was sie von war dass michael kretschmer
den sieger zieht haben der sächsische
ministerpräsident okay sie jetzt auch
sie sagen nur dann will ich nicht
vorgreifen mich schon klar so kurz vor
der wahl wollen sie das fast jetzt
endlich aufmachen das fass mit atommüll
aber das ist da sich die überlegungen
die überlegung und gehen weil für mich
persönlich noch ein ganzes schritt
weiter ich habe das auch geschrieben ich
habe das auch immer wieder gesagt es
gibt mittlerweile die vierte und fünfte
generation von kernkraftwerken
wir haben gerade ein großes patent aus
deutschland heraus nach kanada verkauft
da hätte man sogar die alten brennstäbe
nutzen können wir wären in der lage
große teile der endlagerung zu lösen mit
neuen kraftwerkstypen das ist in
deutschland kein thema das zurzeit
konsensfähig ist also mache ich mir da
allenfalls theoretisch gedanken darüber
wie wirtschaftsminister
stehen sie vor genau diesen frage ich
würde zumindest in einer solchen
situation der deutschen öffentlichkeit
mal szenarien vorlägen und sagen da
stehen wir das sind die optionen die wir
haben und jetzt muss auch politische
entscheidungen treffen ich würde
versuchen realistisch einzuschätzen was
möglich ist und was nicht möglich ist
und ich will vor allem sagen wir hören
jetzt mal endlich auf mit verboten und
reden wir nur über das was möglich ist
und was wir dann auch politisch wollen
soll der jamaica gehen vor schäfer
werden sie das hören also was ja jetzt
hier in der luft liegt und das war am
sonntag zu spüren ist doch die frage
dieses große tabu sozusagen der
deutschen politik atomkraftwerk wer
spricht es als erster aus ist doch die
frage also erst mal verboten da würde
ich mir wünschen dass dieses de facto
ausbau verbot der windkraft was von csu
und cdu in bayern und in nordrhein
westfalen auf den weg gebracht worden
ist endlich da gelegen wird ist nicht
die die rücknahme der ausbau flächen das
problem sondern wie gesagt die
möglichkeit bei den ausschreibeverfahren
mit denen geringe ausbau raten als
erster zum dritten mal sagen ganz groß
raus schäfer können sie lösen wie viele
neue
windkraftanlagen sind im letzten jahr in
baden württemberg gebaut worden unter 10
einen erzählt er die reden von dem land
das geheimlabor zehn jahren von
branchenbüchern ministerpräsidenten
geführt wird genauer gesagt das problem
ist baden wird besser bitten haft
anlagen in den ausschreibeverfahren auf
bundesebene bewohner auch keinen grund
für den fall ist muss weil wir genau so
lang ist wie die gärten und das liegt
eben auch an der 10h regelung die diese
abstandsregeln vermehrt und damit die
fläche zurücknimmt für den ausbau der
windanlagen aber jetzt ist ja die frage
was machen wir jetzt atomkraft ab das
ist das was in der luft ist nicht
richtig weil wir doch gesehen haben dass
diese technologie nicht sicher ist und
dass wir noch millionen jahre mit dem
müll zu tun haben und genau deshalb und
es ist übrigens auch keine klimaneutrale
technologie wenn man jetzt irgendwelche
neuen atomkraftwerke gebaut aber sie
sagt ganz andere co2 bilanz die es ist
eine andere ziele öffentlich die polizei
innovativer jetzt das geld was man für
teure neue anlagen in der atomenergie
selbst wenn das politisch wollte
aufwendet kann man in erneuerbare
energien stecken das geld wurde da
wieder fehlen und ehrlich gesagt ist es
auch vom aufwand her viel weniger
aufwendigen windkraftwerk hin zu bauen
wenn wir mal die ausbauziele im
erneuerbaren energie gesetz ändern
würden und eben die planungsprozesse
beschleunigen da sind wir uns glaube ich
einige märz dass das passieren muss und
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger vor ort
mitnehmen zum beispiel durch
genossenschaftliche windanlagen und wir
haben noch gar nicht über solar geredet
solar ist eben auch ein wichtiger teil
wo wir eben sagen müssen auf jedes neue
dach und auf jedes neu sanierte dach
muss eine solaranlage drauf damit wir
überhaupt diese ziele noch erreichen
aber es ist eben mit erneuerbaren
energien möglich bis 20.30 wie auch
mehrere wissenschaftliche studien
festgestellt haben es ist ambitioniert
aber es ist möglich und deswegen frage
ich mich warum wir uns jetzt wieder auf
diese technologien der vergangenheit
konzentrieren wenn es doch eigentlich
darum gehen musste da jetzt hin zu
kommen und die investition auch dafür
bereitzustellen ist das
wolkenkuckucksheim ist das wohl aber
dass wir uns hier bauen ich bin das was
bilder ja sehr interessant weil es ja
eigentlich sehr konservatives darf ein
astra
ich finde es interessant dass ihr das
wort ambitioniert benutzen weil ich mich
frage also ist ja der punkt das ist
grüner landesbeteiligung gibt eine
regierung ist ein wichtiger punkt und
auch mit blick darauf dass wir entweder
die ampel oder jamaika bekommen kann ich
mir sehr gut vorstellen dass diese
ambitionierten ziele sollten selbst
sollten die grünen damit in die
koalitionsverhandlungen gehen ja nicht
zu 100 prozent
erfüllt werden und wenn wir uns auch die
wahlprogramme anschauen es gibt eine
ganz tolle kurve die zeigt wie nahe die
einzelnen programme an dem 1,5 grad ziel
dran sind und da ist die fdp viel weiter
weg als die union und sie können sich ja
trotzdem die ampel vorstellen das heißt
eigentlich ist ja jetzt schon klar dass
die kompromissbereitschaft da sein muss
und dass wir nicht eine absolute lösung
bekommen werden das heißt ich glaube
schon ein wenig
vergangenheitsbewältigung um dann darauf
zu schauen
kann man den besten kompromiss
aushandeln ist da dazu gehört aber auch
die frage wie gehen wir damit um wenn
wir defizite haben wenn wir mehr
importieren müssen und kann man ist auch
verantworten dann zu sagen okay wenn
deren der fall eintrifft dann müssen wir
halt aus polen importieren die sowieso
schon angst davor haben dass das
passiert
weil das wohl übrigen blätter und die
wirtschaft basiert auf kohlekraftwerken
das ist dort das ding also mehr als 12
geht nicht genau dann ist man dann sagt
okay da kann man dieses greenwashing
laufen unsere eigenen bilanz sagen das
ist nicht unser ja wir bei uns weiter
aus das ist schon eine schwierige frage
wo man aber auch sagen muss die union
hätte sich durchaus darum kümmern können
dass die dass der ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien jetzt viel weiter
ist das heißt dann muss man sich
einerseits eingestehen dass man
vielleicht bei der kernkraft zu schnell
war und andererseits den anderen zu
langsam sodann ist die schuldfrage
geklärt wo der eine druck kann von dazu
schnell und die union hat vielleicht
auch falsch entschieden das heißt sie
sind trotzdem einen punkt wir haben
überhaupt keinen raum mehr für so eine
absolute lösung es geht gerade um
kompromisse die nächste regierung wird
keine absolute entscheidung treffen
hundertprozentig erneuerbare energien
ausbaut